hey ich weiterhin euch geht aber ich bin
jemand der probiert immer mehrere neue
sachen aus also wenn ich in dem
restaurant bestellen oder einem
restaurant essen geht dann bestellt
einen nicht zweimal hintereinander die
gleichen sachen sondern probiert immer
was neues aus und ich dachte mir dass
mich die leute auf meinem video um
letztlich in dem supermarkt gegangen und
habe dort den verrücktesten sachen
gekauft ich finden konnte
also dachten die wahrscheinlich nur die
allerwenigsten von euch schon mal
gegessen haben dafür entweder ganz neue
lachen oder auch dafür wie man einfach
nicht kennen
ihr körper scheint gar nicht vorstellen
wie lange wir gerade im supermarkt nach
den verrücktesten sachen gesucht haben
aber die haben uns für euch gemacht gern
gesehen
ich finde dazu eine verkäuferin weniger
am tag ein bisschen komisch aber ich
suche verrückte sachen weil die
verrücktesten sachen kaufen will und wer
mich komisch angeguckt und hab gesagt
wäre aber eine coole idee
beginnen wir mit nummer eins ist
verrückt aber so ganz interessant und
zwar wenn bonbon also wochen mit eis
gefüllt sind ziemlich lang ist eine so
was noch nie gesehen ich stehe doch
lustig vor schlecht schmeckt auch noch
einfach nur wie der asb von der marke
habe ich probiere jetzt auf wir sind
jetzt beteiligt dass du selbst wie das
format vom band aber schauen wir mal
schlecht genau wie ein uhrwerk ich denke
deshalb auch nicht verrückt dass ich
noch so die am wenigsten verrückte sache
als ich werde mich ein bisschen steigern
wahrscheinlich weil ich sowieso alle auf
diesen superscharfen wege gehen
wahrscheinlich allerletztes mittel
möglich als auch nicht zu schlecht wird
nicht toleriert damit ziemlich übergehen
kann es auch gewesen um zu überprüfen ob
es wirklich eine gefüllte künftig schon
da kann man ganz cool so dass jetzt das
ist die verrückteste sache aller zeiten
werden aber die nebensache bis sie mich
zurück und vielleicht gerne einige ferne
sunshine ist das nämlich auf einer tv
show bekannt ich rede von
andernach schiff also schiff gehörte
genau genommen wird dass kartoffelchips
und anna abpfiff ich werde jetzt mal nur
auf die anderen acht chips konzentrieren
wird auf jeden fall glaube ich deutlich
weniger extrem als normale das ist schon
mal ganz gut bei fans nicht wirklich mag
im moment befindet gesunde ernährung wer
regelmäßig trainieren und so werde ich
die woche wahrscheinlich auch so schnell
nicht aufessen besteht ja der hammer und
jedoch in der box alles klar und örtlich
muss ich sagen wo das riecht wie
seelisches curry
wir hatten also ein anderer schöpft aus
so sieht das auch was mit verpackungen
zu tun die nach dem cool aussieht die
anderen chefs darauf das ist ein schein
ein ananas geschäft aber hey bevor ich
irgendwie urteile probiere ich doch erst
mal ab ob vielleicht nicht erhält
vielleicht eigentlich ganz geil
also wir dann auch so normalverbraucher
chips zu schmecken normalpapier
zurücknehmen ich möchte die
kartoffelchips mit kari also es schmeckt
so als würde ich jetzt auch einmal auf
essen wenn ich mich nicht ganz bewusst
ernähren würde dann schon abend
drei stück vom können überraschend
lecker muss ich sagen die nächste sache
habe ich auch im supermarkt gesehen aber
ich dachte mir das kannst du nicht und
frau handelt sich um diese kleiner apfel
kerne und fragt waren und gar nicht dass
es so wenig also erstmal liebling slogan
just in place with respect so helfert
jahren aber überlegen wie man ganz genau
dass diese firma nach wien im verlauf
ihrer hülle ihr vielleicht wisst jeder
kanal abbildungen würde aufgrund des
tableaus man nicht schälen und in
plastik packen und packen noch einen
kleinen fehler ein
es ist wichtig aber es wäre doch
verrückt gewesen und wollte rechts links
auf euch zumindest mal zeigen
natürlich auch mit geben dass du was
eigentlich echt überflüssig ist so leute
für die nächste sache die ich sein
möchte muss sich an den kühlschrank
gehen und haltet euch fest richtig
verrückt einfach mal das gibt erstmal
komisch aus wenn nicht also ist ein
champ burger und zwar ist das einen
burger ohne fleisch also eine toilette
ohne fleisch 75 prozent shanxi aus
kopierten ich bin sehr gespannt wie das
schmeckt testen jetzt auch ich bin ja
von den fischen wollte die dinger
reinmachen arbeit dafür fördermittel
haben mich das öffne dich rief weniger
schlimm als ich dachte
keinesfalls darf es ein bisschen ehrlich
dass jemand sagt das riechen ehrlich
bist weiß ich schon aber es wird aber
nicht so
ok jetzt meisten jemals brauchen wir ja
ist wahrscheinlich der gesündeste burger
wenn man zu nennen kann den jemals
jemand in seinem leben gegessen hat hier
ist was ganz
wir haben ja weissbrodt salat und
violette ich bin überlegen sich gebraten
deutliche appetitlicher aus als um
gebraten ich klappt jetzt mal zu sagen
und wer weiß vielleicht wird es ab
sofort mein abendessen bürgern in die
spur und stattdessen richtig guter
gleich ersatz also das ist echt nicht
schön aber in den bergen ist ein relativ
teuer zweiten diesen scheinen kosten
drei euro recht gut dass auf jeden fall
für eine vegetarische ernährung als auch
vegan ist weiß ich nicht genau aber echt
stark also ohne spaß extrem gut das
schmeckt richtigkeit
da kommen wir natürlich sache hat ein
video vor auf gekriegt hat dann haben
wir das uns gesehen und das hat mir auch
die inspiration in dieses video zu
machen
wir haben hier ein pick-up riegel
mutprobe
und hier steht ab 16 während wir das
durchgezogen wird also auch der wirklich
nicht an unter 16 jährige verkauft wird
aber anscheinend bei der zutatenliste
steht der schokoladentafel nicht
verloren
13 prozent gleichkommt prozent von dem
religiösen anstandes pure chili kommen
dafür an welche tv das riecht schon
richtig scharf vor leute aber wer das
sieht genauso aus wie normales pick up
ist das bedeutet ich könnte damit
vielleicht mal lukas in bastad franken
oder so verspannt sich schlimmst ist ja
die bevorstehe
ich hoffe dass wieder gefallen das wort
die vermahlen bisschen wenig hatte ich
nach ihr sind da vielleicht auch in
bhutan vergleich mal in kommentaren ein
leichter lassen und ihr problem recht
meinen großen bitten
ab 16 aber es ist auch verfügbar
april ist also ich glaube lukas zum
beispiel gemacht fand das team für sowas
schon umbauen
wie wäre es denn wenn man es einer
angebissen hat dann sieht man schon
haben wir das jetzt erkennt dass er so
ein bisschen rote zeug auskommt also man
kann erkennen also ich finde es
eigentlich interessant wo sich tragen
aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht kaufen
sondern wie gesagt zum ausprobieren ist
das super cool aber wo regelmäßig kaufen
will ich mir nicht dafür ist okay leute
dann hoffe ich mal dass wir keine fakten
hält kritik in die kommentare
wir sehen uns dann nicht mal wieder und
bis dahin wirklich ärger dafür zu
geschafft hast wenn du sogar jetzt noch
waren ist mit so ziemlich cool